das ist eingeschaltet hat also soll das
jetzt hallo und er hat gedacht da die
weihnachtszeit ist habe ich gedacht ich
bringe heute mal ein paar leute zusammen
ohne dass sie es wissen denn nämlich
sowie die optik doch gesehen ist also
egal was ich hier machen heute nach ist
übrigens in kanada abonnieren warum sage
ich dass du mal direkt am anfang ohne
euch irgendwie davon überzeugt zu haben
jetzt noch alle zuschauer nämlich nicht
nur vier mal ist dass sie abonniert auf
vielen dank an die mandarinen die heute
für guten ton sorgen
das ist in den letzten zwei videos
passiert wird das ist doch mal starten
ich habe sind wir nun mal rausgesucht
das wird so witzig sagt max so will man
der sache ist natürlich dass die leute
gleichzeitig rangehen müssen wenn jetzt
jemand bedeutend früher angehen müssen
wir probieren denn hin zu halten bis sie
miteinander reden kann und direkt auf
laut 31 hallo
felix kirchner mein name ja haben sie
auch mit erfahrung
die ersten zwei nummern sind verbracht
die deutschen einfach komplett beklagt
wahrscheinlich verbrochen haben es
kommen gleich da und nummer die mit
sicherheit nicht angehoben werden und
dass du hier bist aber mit aller das
passt natürlich sagt es ist also als der
julien beim letztens da wir uns auf
jeden fall besser ausgerüstet als du uns
jetzt vielleicht sollten wir aber
weitermachen mit zwei konkurrierenden
fast-food-ketten deswegen habe ich ein
paar nummern von mcdonald's und burger
king rausgesucht und die lassen wir
jetzt mal miteinander kommunizieren
stellen wir uns das nicht auch noch mal
mit ihm so in das feld bei kosten von
mit herz machen hier diverse
ausgerichtete zum sonntag 25 nummern
angerufen wo ich einfach nur leute vom
arbeiten ab gerade ende 2019 und wir
machen telefon
das gibt mir so kommen auf einem kanal
sind das übrigens teil das in meinem
eigenen video eigentlich nichts machen
außer zwischen den leuten zu sitzen
irgendwas machen uns lachen jetzt habe
ich ein gutes gefühl
[Musik]
hallo ja nochmal hobbys wiederholte sie
[Applaus]
rückte die revolte sprechen sie haben
mir ich hab dir ja das ist genau das was
ich eine sache die mir gab mittendrin
ein feld lasst uns dieses mal probieren
die likes und die kommentare auf einem
level zu halten und schreibt in die
kommentare wenig als nächstes anrufen
soll der club macht es jetzt leider
keine riesige konversation daraus
entstanden auch die warte auf jeden fall
gut kommt haben wir der einheit gedacht
haben sie anrufe wegen der shake
maschine also eine maschine kaputt
lustig gesehen hast wie also von zehn
jahre ja und das war so das war so was
anfällt ja das war so dreist deswegen
also aber geil
die crazy das sein muss wenn du
angerufen die es auf der anderen leitung
aber ihr wollt ist wir fest davon
überzeugt ist dass du nicht mehr hallo
kann sie nicht
ich finde aber jetzt sollten wir mal
probieren die freunde von uns reagieren
also wir haben jetzt elf tragen sondern
lieber mit normaler nummer anrufen die
denken dass du anrufst dann sprechen die
aber mit was geht brauche bist du auf
arbeit erwarte ich muss auch noch kurz
was machen was ist beruflich halte ich
an also sollte das jetzt auch noch gar
nicht nicht mal der arbeit gestört wir
rund um zwei verschiedene nummern an und
sagten die einfache retten das helfen
das grab mit jakob gesprochen und er
dachte dass du sebastian oder und
wie wird das ok meister gesprochen
die freuen uns sehr auf seinen appell
die partie manchester
wir haben also okay weil man weiß dass
es war ein montag 2 das war's perfektes
jagt man die oh warte kurzer perfekt
gepasst nicht einfach zwei jahre
faktisch ein moment kurz normal
funktioniert nicht wir wollen leute
anrufen kann man die roten raben anderen
handy marken wollten euch ohne das
wissen mit nach der brief video für
sebastian und jakob hat es gab schon
wunderbar und wir reden ja gut kelly das
war schon was passieren marco nicht
gegen markwort selbst eine airports
besucht und ein mikrofon zu futter kann
man mit anrufen und viel lustiger und
einem 1 1 in stuttgart
dennis im köcher
im moment sind das motto hallo hallo
taxi fahrer kann weil ich immer dicker
kommt aber was möchten sie führen bei
uns gerade
wir haben gehört bei unseren gerufen ich
weiß nicht was das ist aller ehren wert
oh ja
edeka aktivmarkt packen wir gemeinsam
mit dem mitten im spiel ja gefallen dass
man das nicht weiter gegeben und
natürlich über land und leute arbeiten
also soll ich weiß es aus den jeweiligen
leben sieht oder von den personen wir
wollen sich ab packen einfach ein penner
spaß
wir schlagen ein fach bringen der den
verstoß gegen die datenschutz und
verordnungen oder straße 25
jetzt kommen aber das große finale
letztlich würde es werden leute die
dafür sorgen dass es uns in deutschland
gut steht und vernünftige politik die
dafür sorgen soll vernünftigen in ihrem
freund ich nenne die grünen ich hätte
nicht damit gerechnet dass es so
funktioniert das denn sonst machen
wir bereiten erreicht weil der mensch
sich nummer bereiche ja ja bereit seien
zu geben
mit wem spreche ich ja in köln perfekt
wir haben heute machen so gute politik
für unser land etwas zu sehen dass der
spaß steckt allerdings in der video
beschreibung ich bedanke mich auch sonst
im wasser und erinnern sollen wie das
ist wenn dir dieses video nicht leicht
sei die perfekte euro merklich höhere
witzig das video aber jedes video was im
moment machen dass witziger als reaktion